à paris cet après midi lors de la
discussion du budget de la police à
l'assemblée nationale jean louis debré a
passé en revue les différents fronts qui
réclament selon le ministre de
l'intérieur une vigilance identique que
ce soit la dérive de l'immigration
irrégulière mais aussi bien sur le
terrorisme les résultats obtenus
sont la réponse
la plus cinglante que pouvaient recevoir
ceux qui n'ont pour fonds de commerce
que le dénigrement systématique
la manipulation ou la malveillance
aux sceptiques
au blasé
aux irresponsables
aux professionnels de la désinformation
je dis simplement
messieurs
regardez le travail accompli depuis
trois mois est usée nous sur les
résultats on n'a jamais fait dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
aussi bien et aussi vite il faut vous en
souveniez